who are the loggers trying to to uh
destroy the Amazon
can you say a little bit more about it
is that as a threat to the the Amazon
rainforest a lot of them are really
close friends of mine they're they're
they're people that need to make a
living and they're jungle people who you
know the rainforest is a very
challenging especially the Amazon is a
very challenging environment so you have
these people who they have a chainsaw
they have a job opportunity they go out
and they cut the trees and a lot of
these guys grew up fishing they grew up
in the jungle they know how to do it and
so for them it's a way to like they also
love it so this is the thing these are
outdoorsmen these are guys that love the
jungle and so they you know in the 90s
we had the mahogany boom where they went
out after the mahogany and you almost
can't find a mahogany tree in the jungle
anymore
and and if you want to talk about like
carbon sequestration and the rainforest
the the ancient Hardwoods hold like 60
percent of the carbon of the whole
rainforest they have an outsized
disproportionate Mass from from that
ancient density of the wood
and so these these these loggers go out
and they cut the wood that's most
valuable and then they bring it back to
town and they sell it and then people
like us buy it and put it on our kitchen
floors yeah
and you know and so
the thing is is I should you know when I
got to the Amazon it was you know
loggers are the bad guys
and if you talk to you know a lot of
like the phds that I worked with down
there were you know always very at odds
with the miners at odds with the with
the loggers and then I'd be with JJ and
JJ would sit down and he'd be like hey
let's pour a drink oh they have masato
let's all sit down like we'd all be
chilling and throwing them back with a
bunch of loggers
and and then those the opportunity
through through not vilifying these
people came to be like oh these are
these are these guys are great you know
and then of course out in the wild every
now and then something will happen
you'll see somebody's boat flipped over
and you go you go help them out and then
that that creates a certain type of
kinship so they're ultimately people who
love
who love the same thing you love often
yeah even if they don't love it they're
people that aren't necessarily looking
to destroy it I've met loggers who have
looked at at trees they're about to cut
and gone ah this is a shame start it up
you know they're just like this is where
the paycheck comes from